ومعنا من مدينه سرمدا الشماليه ادلب رائد
الصالح مدير الدفاع المدني السوري اهلا
وسهلا بك عندما نتحدث الان عن الانتهاء من
مرحله البحث
والانتقال الى مرحله البحث والانتشال
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالضبط
تحياتي لك والاستاذ المشاهدين حقيقه يعني
ذلك باننا فقدنا الامل تماما ان نجد اي
اشخاص احياء تحت الانقراض فننتقل الى
انتشال الجثث الموجوده تحت الانقاض وليقوم
لنقوم بتسليمها لاهلهم وهذا لذلك انا
تحدثت اليوم في المؤتمر الصحفي واعتذرت
من شعبنا العظيم باننا اذا قصرنا ولكن قلت
لهم ايضا باننا بزلنا كل طاقتنا وبزلنا كل
جهدنا حتى نستطيع ان نصل الى كل الاشخاص
الاحياء ولكن يمكن ان قدراتنا الماديه
قدراتنا اللوجستيه قد خانتنا في بعض
اللحظات
[موسيقى]
قام باقصى ما يمكنه ولكن تلك هي حدود
الامكانيات للاسف الشديد